je ne peux pas un peu vite là
on va faire la gueule pendant tout le
voyage
on se connaît pas ça va être long à côté
de moi mais j'aurais les assis à côté de
toi juste à côté
antoine on ne sait pas ce que je le sais
je sens tu ta mère qu'est-ce qui dit-on
horoscope que tu vas rencontrer un type
extraordinaire c'est cff selon mamour
cisse mari ça me tape combien d'heures
de vol à partir de maintenant mode
domptage tu prends le petit l'assaut et
tu va choper un veau ok tu te souviens
tu aurais fait je crois qu'hier bouger
qui ça lemay vais tuer trois ans je
ferai tout je rencontrais que des
connards et maintenant tout mon
investissement
les pinceaux mike antoine par fait quoi
là c'est bien ce qui bouge qui
n'interroge pas sur les qu'astrid à la
maternelle
je peux vous offrir un verre j'ai jamais
passé une heure avec un bon coup vous
avez une heure on va vous
la tour ce sommet de sa [ __ ] qu'il a
voulu emmener maintenant comment tu
parles je vous préviens ne couchera pas
ensemble bonsoir aussi dans son genre je
les suis dans l'app est chantée par
alain jeantet jalouse des mythes folle
dégage je vais quand même d'expliquer
mon avis vous retrouvé miraculeusement
la femme de votre vie et puis tout se
casse la gueule
à cela on pressent la dca revient
costumes et roule une grosse paire